and
have you
participated in aquaman two
i have
and tell us about that
uh i had to fight to
i fought really hard to stay in the
movie they
um didn't want to
include me in the field objection your
honor hearsay i'll sustain the ejection
did you ultimately were you ultimately
able to get
to
film in aquaman two
a
very part down version of that role yes
okay what if anything changed in the
script they took away uh a lot of
objection you're on earth you're saying
i think she can lock a foundation
overruled as the script
go ahead i
was given a script and then
given new versions of the script
that
had taken away
scenes that the
that had action in it that had that
depicted
my character
and uh
and
another character
without giving any spoilers away you
know they're two characters fighting
with one another and
they
they basically took a bunch out of my
role they didn't
yeah they just removed a bunch oh and
what if any leverage did you have to
negotiate a higher salary beyond the 2
million objections speculation
sustain the objection what if any effort
did you make
to
negotiate
a higher salary for your participation
i couldn't renegotiate my contract
and why not
objection this calls for hearsay
and speculation do you know why
it's still the same objections your
honor sustain the objection
you